[Música]
gabón qué tal
vengo la verdad es que vengo
tremendamente preocupado por las últimas
noticias que acabo de ver en la bbc
son del último boletín horario la bbc
habla a las hace escasos minutos hablaba
en su último boletín horario que ya no
sé ni en que ni en qué hora vivo habla
de enfrentamientos entre fuerzas de la
otan y fuerzas rusas habla de serios
incidentes no sólo eso además hablan
también de 230 soldados estadounidenses
fuerzas de la otan que han resultado ya
muertos de al menos 230 soldados que ya
han fallecido por fuego ruso más
titulares que está dando la bbc parece
que en el palacio de buckingham la
familia real ha sido evacuada a un sitio
más seguro y además se está difundiendo
esta está alerta una alerta del
ministerio del interior también del
ministerio de defensa pidiendo a los
ciudadanos británicos que vayan a
refugio bueno estas estas las
informaciones que creo os tenía que
contar por qué
es la situación parece verdaderamente
crítica y ahora ya sí vamos vamos con la
charla pero antes antes quiero haceros
una pregunta
cuántos de vosotros ha retwitteado algo
de lo que lo acabamos de contar
bueno esto no demuestra nada esto sólo
demuestra misma las dotes de
interpretación y aparte que han hablado
me habían prometido que no iban a hablar
de fake news
al presentar esta charla y entonces ya
me lo han estropeado un poco esto sólo
demuestra que no tengo ningún oscar a la
mejor interpretación pero pero os hacía
esta pregunta porque os quiero demostrar
de alguna manera lo fácil que se
expanden noticias falsas las llamadas
fake news ninguno de vosotros ha
retwitteado esto ninguno de vosotros lo
ha extendido ni en facebook ni en
whatsapp pero pero lo cierto es que se
hizo se hizo y mucho tanto que la propia
bbc tuvo que desmentir un vídeo este
vídeo con semejantes titulares titulares
bomba que llegaron cruzaron océanos y
llegaron incluso a asia áfrica y allí
los propios corresponsales de la bbc en
sus oficinas recibieron llamadas de los
ciudadanos ciudadanos preguntando
verdaderamente esas informaciones eran
ciertas así es que lo dicho hace apenas
unas semanas un par de semanas el 19 de
abril la bbc vía vía portavoz y también
vía comunicados a través de sus redes
sociales tuvo que desvincularse
directamente de noticias como esta el
reto el gran reto de los periodistas del
siglo 21 es que bulos como estos no se
nos cuelen eso es lo que tenemos que
conseguir porque si es verdad la mentira
ha existido siempre pero nunca la
mentira lo ha tenido tan fácil para
extenderse nunca le ha salido tan gratis
extenderse y nunca ha habido tanta gente
dispuesta a comprar las falsedades no lo
digo yo hay estudios que lo demuestran
el mit y el instituto tecnológico de
massachusetts en la revista science el
pasado marzo publicaba todo un estudio
en torno a las noticias falsas cómo
funcionan en twitter y sus datos son
tremendamente
es la mentira en twitter tiene un 70%
más de retweets que la verdad en twitter
y además a la verdad le cuesta seis
veces más expandirse le cuesta seis
veces más que a la mentira llegar a mil
500 usuarios de twitter si ya hablamos
de cadenas twitter entonces ya estamos
hablando de 20 veces más a la verdad le
cuesta 20 veces más expandirse en
twitter en la red social 'twitter'
este estudio del lema te da un ranking
de las noticias que son más virales las
que las que más nos gusta
las mentiras que más nos gusta expandir
en las redes sociales primero están las
noticias relacionadas con la política le
siguen las las leyendas urbanas noticias
económicas en tercer puesto en cuarto
puesto ese con el que arrancábamos esta
charla las que se refieren al terrorismo
y la guerra y por último también parece
que nos gustan mucho los desastres
naturales
vamos a buscar ejemplos teniendo claro
cuál es ese ese ranking vamos a buscar
ejemplos de noticias fake de estos
últimos tiempos siempre teniendo muy
claro que sobre todo las mentiras se
aprovechan de situaciones traumáticas
situaciones traumáticas en las que se
generaliza el estupor se realiza el
asombro y es ahí precisamente ahí donde
la mentira se cuela más fácilmente y
cuando hablamos de situaciones
traumáticas de lo que estamos hablando
es por ejemplo una que me tocó a mí los
atentados de parís los atentados el
bataclán y de las terrazas de parís ahí
se nos colaron muchos muchos face y otro
más reciente la matanza de parkland en
florida allí también se colaron muchos
face y se colaron fake sobre todo en
torno a los propios niños que estaban en
el instituto y niños que después no sé
si lo recordáis pero en varias
manifestaciones también
en protestas bueno se convirtieron esos
niños se convirtieron en todo un símbolo
contra contra las armas en todo un
símbolo anti armas en estados unidos
bueno se llegó a decir de ellos de justo
esos líderes de ese movimiento anti
armas también anti trump se llegó a
decir que esos algunos de esos niños ni
siquiera estuvieron en las aulas cuando
cuando todo ocurría y está en mas
gonzález por ejemplo su foto rompiendo
un ejemplar de la constitución
estadounidense se extendió como la
pólvora por las redes sociales en eeuu
esa foto después se demostró que era un
fake medios como la cnn tuvieron que
desmentir lo tuvieron que decir que todo
había sido fruto de del photoshop
decíamos que las noticias falsas que más
se expanden como la pólvora son las
noticias relacionadas con la política
bueno pues vamos a fijarnos en las
elecciones en eeuu seguimos allí en eeuu
porque hay datos también muy muy
reveladores en los últimos tres meses de
campaña del presidente trump de esas
elecciones que ganó trump han comparado
cómo funcionan en facebook
noticias falsas y noticias verdaderas se
han cogido 20 historias falsas historias
falsas de webs especializadas
en falsas webs especializadas también
como pueden ser blogs partidistas bueno
pues esas noticias falsas a través de
retweets a través de comentarios a
través de compartidos consiguieron ocho
con siete millones de reacciones eso las
noticias falsas en esos tres últimos y
decisivos meses de campaña para la casa
blanca las noticias
las falsas consiguieron ocho con siete
millones de reacciones mientras 20
artículos de los diarios más
prestigiosos hablamos del 'new york
times' hablamos del 'washington post'
hablamos también del huffington post'
bueno pues tuvieron siete con cuatro
millones de reacciones buscamos más
ejemplos en el break sheet el éxito ya
lo llaman la primera elección primera
elección de la era de la post verdad
pues verdad esa palabra que escuchamos
tanto que es esa era
de las redes sociales en la que hemos
pasado a no pensar tanto en los faxes en
las realidades hemos pasado a no prestar
tanta atención a los datos empíricos y
ciertamente probados para fijarnos más
en las vísceras en nuestras emociones y
tomar decisiones de acuerdo con eso con
nuestras emociones en el presi está
ahora el gobierno de theresa may ahora
ha difundido que durante el break sheet
se crearon 400 cuentas twitter que lo
único que hacían era eso difundir
información falsa cuentas twitter que
sitúan en rusia eso bueno cuentas
creadas para difundir fake news durante
el break sí pero aparte están los fakes
que también difundió vendieron los
propios políticos progressive como por
ejemplo boris johnson position son que
hablaba de 78 millones
sugirió que 78 millones de turcos iban a
llegar a gran bretaña si continuaban
si continuaban en la unión europea' y
después todos sabemos lo que pasó
seguimos buscando seguimos buscando más
ejemplos los refugiados sobre los
refugiados también se han difundido
muchos muchísimos fakes hasta
violaciones de niñas menores
hasta hasta también golpes en las
consultas de la seguridad social por
ejemplo aquí está tuvo un gran eco está
esta noticia en la que se hablaba de un
musulmán dando una paliza una paliza a
un médico que le atendía tuvo muchísimo
eco se difundió mucho esa noticia y poco
después pudo saberse que se trataba de
un vídeo grabado hace 10 años era un
vídeo grabado en rusia nada tenía que
ver con refugiados nada tenía que ver
con musulmanes porque porque nos creemos
estas estas noticias bueno tenemos que
hablar de la crisis de del periodismo es
verdad el periodismo está en crisis
aunque en esencia nuestro trabajo ha
cambiado más bien poco nuestro trabajo
sigue siendo enterarnos de lo que pasa
contrastar
y contextualizar en esencia eso ha
cambiado más bien poco pero lo que ha
cambiado y con lo que estamos muy muy
perdidos es la forma de consumir nuestra
información en nuestra tele por ejemplo
no sabemos muy bien a dónde vamos en qué
en qué nos vamos a convertir nos vamos a
convertir en plataformas no ahora mismo
no sabemos dónde vamos como tampoco
saben a dónde van la prensa escrita no
sabe si tiene que tirar más para
internet si tiene que dejar de vender
periódicos o no y eso por ejemplo esa
crisis en la que no sabemos a dónde
vamos
ha hecho que se cuestione nuestra verdad
nuestra verdad antes antes se decía lo
han dicho en la tele era era verdad
ahora por haberlo dicho en la tele nada
nada es verdad la verdad se cuestiona
muchísimo más y hay muchísima más gente
con ganas de conocer otras verdades nos
relacionan a los medios de comunicación
nos relacionan con líneas editoriales
nos relacionan con con grandes grupos de
poder es lógico que teniendo eso en la
cabeza muchos digan para no acabar me de
tragar esto voy a buscar otras verdades
y es
y precisamente donde los generadores de
fake news han encontrado su nicho de
mercado que hay detrás de esos
generadores de fake news bueno tenemos
que tener claro que tienen tres
objetivos quienes investigan las fake
news agentes agentes de seguridad que
investigan se investigan fe y news y
quién hay detrás de esas noticias falsas
hablan de noticias con tres objetivos
principalmente primero están las que
intentan generar alarma social para
desestabilizar están también las que
reafirman ideales como por ejemplo ese
ese vídeo antimusulmán islamófobos y
también también están quienes quienes
intentan obtener dinero no hay que
olvidar lo que se intenta obtener mucho
dinero a través de estas pequeñas tanto
que ya se habla incluso de granjas de
las fake news y no sé si este dato
estaba muy comprobado o no tal vez no
tendría que poner aquí pero bueno
tendría que traer porque está muy
comprobado pero bueno lo cierto es que
se habla ya de al menos 30 países 30
países con granjas de fake news hay webs
páginas web
generan entre 10.000 y 40.000 dólares al
mes y lo hacen con noticias que se crean
en tan solo 10 minutos y detrás de esas
noticias muchas veces hay jóvenes recién
salidos de la universidad que lo único
que buscan es conseguir dinero
las redes sociales tienen también un
gran peso en todo esto las redes
sociales también tienen una gran
responsabilidad y lo ha enseñado el
escándalo de facebook redes sociales que
se han preocupado bastante poco porque
como usuarios tengamos un servicio de
calidad y de lo que más se han
preocupado ha sido de que el negocio
funcione así es como con amazon amazon
sabe por ejemplo que es lo que compramos
google sabe qué es lo que buscamos
facebook sabe qué es lo que compartimos
e instagram conoce nuestras coordenadas
y así es como tenemos hoy aquí el gran
hermano que orwell describía en su
novela 1984 el gran hermano del que ya
se hablaba a finales de los 40 que
podemos hacer contra todos estos bulos
bueno pues contra todos estos bulos lo
que sobre todo podemos hacer es
periodismo de calidad creo que contra
las fake news el principal antídoto es
el de un periodismo el de llevar a cabo
un periodismo de calidad que no se nos
olvide nunca ese contrastar del que en
muchas redacciones cada vez más se pasa
no y que podéis hacer vosotros como
usuarios porque estoy hablando de los
periodistas pero que podéis hacer
vosotros como usuarios porque porque
vosotros también sois parte de la
solución os recomiendo vivamente una
cuenta twitter
maldito bulo es de nuestros compañeros
de lasexta [ __ ] hemeroteca seguro que
lo recordáis bueno pues también han
creado una cuenta maldito bulo en la que
van destapando bulos como el de el
musulmán que golpeaba al médico que
resultó ser falso
bueno pues esa cuenta da algunas
recomendaciones sobre que podéis hacer
como usuarios contra las noticias falsas
primero tenéis que desconfiar de las
exclusivas sobre todo si son de webs de
medios de comunicación que desconfía y
tenéis que ir más allá del titular
porque muchas veces el mero titular
puede puede parecer una noticia real
pero si después seguimos leyendo
descubrimos que eso es una tremenda
falsedad y tenéis que alejarlos también
de citas y alertas falsas sobre todo si
no tienen
ni fuente ni fecha y recordáis cómo
hemos empezado esta charla hemos
empezado con un vídeo que se hizo viral
sobre todo vía whatsapp y vía facebook
con esa alerta de los ministerios
ministerio de defensa y de y del
interior que alertaban a la ciudadanía
bueno pues recordarlo las alertas no
llegan por por whatsapp
la solución la solución tiene que ser
periodismo con mayúsculas eso está claro
pero quiero terminar con un mensaje
esperanzador porque es verdad que las
fake news las facebook
muchas veces se ven como una auténtica
amenaza para este periodismo del siglo
21 sin embargo tenemos que verlas como
la oportunidad tienen que ser toda una
oportunidad porque yo creo que nos
estamos dando cuenta del problema y de
la amenaza de las pequeños prueba de
ello es que hoy estamos aquí debatiendo
sobre sobre ese tema nos estamos dando
cuenta y en el momento en el que nos
damos cuenta entonces vamos a dar
todavía mayor valor a los medios de
comunicación libres de fake news
aquellos medios de comunicación que sean
capaces de poner la mano en el fuego y
puedan realmente decirnos nosotros
estamos libres de falsedades esos son
los que verdaderamente van a tener un
gran valor y los que vamos a saber
valorar lo dicho el periodismo con
mayúsculas es el reto eskerrik asko
[Aplausos]
[Música]